wenn du auch nicht genug bekommen kannst
von der Subway georle Soße dann machst
du dir einfach selbst die Basis des
Mayonnaise 250 Gramm ab in einen
mixgefäß so nichts verschwenden als
nächstes Ketchup 30 Gramm grober sind 15
Gramm und natürlich chipoli Chilis die
sind in Adobe Soße eingelegt sehr sehr
geil kommen noch ungefähr so ein
Teelöffel Soße mit Next ab halbe Zitrone
ohne Kerne am besten wenn ihr die in die
Hand pressen und bleiben die Kerne
draußen und für die typische orangene
Farbe geräucherte Paprika ungefähr zwei
Teelöffel Stabmixer nehmen und ab geht's
und in eine quetschflasche abfüllen
Deckel drauf und